is
explore our world
meet the devs
see the games
join us
hi everyone i'm nylon kumar and i'm very
excited to be co-hosting the first
ubisoft forward with the talented
youssef mcgee
today's show is all about getting up
close and in depth with all the exciting
games we have in production here at
ubisoft
i'm yusuf but there's no time to waste
so let's head straight to the streets of
futuristic london
and see what the hackers of deadset are
getting into
the illegal paintings spreading
subversive and hostile messaging over
the last few weeks across london are not
the work of several people as was
originally believed but the work of an
individual
the
with the criminals
[Applause]
[Applause]
authorities recommend not to approach
the individual
first they came for the foreigners and i
did not speak out
because i was not a foreigner
then they came for the protesters
and i did not speak out
because i was not a protester
then they came for the journalists
but i did not speak out
because i was not a journalist
and then they came for street artists
but i did not speak out
because i am not a street artist
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
no realized that eventually
they'd come for me
and there would be no one left to speak
for me
[Applause]
[Music]
right oh my where are we off to sir
let's get the hell out here
after a long night london is in chaos
there's a welcome gift for our new
members for the disappearance of the
criminal you could have told me it was a
bloody
costume partly
try it off the new key suspect has been
identified as david ford a 43 year old
london taxi driver
he has no criminal record but is
currently believed to be a terrorist
people have been asked not to approach
him the authorities advise all residents
i'm clint hawking
clinton has been a longtime creative
force here at ubisoft and now he's
bringing this vision to watch dogs
legion
um so yeah what we just saw was an
amazing short film by the director
alberto mielgo that uh was inspired by
watchdogs legion and looks at at the
game and the universe and the characters
through his incredible artistic vision
and visual style the city needs a
resistance like the film watchdog's
legion tells the story of ordinary
heroes setting aside their differences
in order to come together as a
collective and to fight for a positive
change
you can literally recruit and play
anyone who you see in the open world you
profile people that are interesting to
you you help them with their problem you
play their origin mission just help me
get some closure and i'll do whatever
you want sounds like a dead sex problem
leave it to us and that's how you
recruit them into your team and then
they become the heroes of the game and
and the stars of your story and what you
doing in my flat you with albion
please think more underground
you with albion i'm tickled but think
more underground what did sick
yeah right nam che guevara you're done
and they make the story not only you
know unique to them but unique to you as
the player and personal to you because
they're you know heroes that you've
chosen and invested in
what would i say to fans i guess i'd say
you know uh take care of yourselves stay
safe welcome to the resistance
our london town
a modern metropolis
built on history and prosperity
only took 12 000 years to build it up
and one night to tear it all down
oh my god
listen up
get all your units to move in and lock
down the city
with london under attack by a mysterious
terrorist
the government turns to a private
military company called albion to keep
everyone safe what could possibly go
wrong
ladies and gentlemen mr nigel cass ceo
of albion
he's kindly stepped up to establish
order
[Music]
understand this i will not allow anyone
not even myself
to jeopardize this
he will stop at nothing to permanently
control the city
london will be the first city in the
world to be made truly safe
nigel's not the only opportunist who's
taken a liking to this fair city
meet mary kelly head of the most
powerful crime syndicate in london be
sure and spread the word
she and her goons are using the dark web
to sell everything from party pills to
people
this microchip is scary i know but i've
got to keep tracks on my merchandise
than i you made me a slave
you do not want to ruffle her feathers
with the city out on its arse it now
falls on you to build a resistance and
take back london
all right everyone
faces on guns out
any of the brave londoners you see
walking the streets
can be recruited into your team
like him
her
or even her
everyone could become your next secret
weapon
in our first mission we need to get some
dirt on nigel cass and that means
breaking into albion headquarters inside
the tower of london
all the hardy souls you see here are
people we have recruited from the
streets of london they all have unique
abilities and you're free to tackle this
mission with whoever you like
dear god my eyes
brightly
zip up get to work and let's never talk
about this again
like everyone in dedsec arthur can hack
pretty much whatever
but as a construction worker he has a
particular set of tools that make him
handy
he can even call his own cargo drone
perfect for gate crashing when you're
not invited
and who needs a regular old gun when you
have a bloody nail gun
come here
[ __ ] boy
[Music]
jesus christ what is that thing
perhaps we could approach this mission
differently if you'd rather keep your
distance we've got you covered
amy is a drone expert
[Music]
what have we here a real tech
connoisseur
hate spiders but love this one
what an adorable creepy crawler
here we are let's class the place up
a drone expert does have the unique
ability to summon their own drone this
little darling is fast and stealthy
i'm reading incoming drones
she can also hack enemy drones turning
the tide in her favor
and if you are not into direct
confrontation there are more ways than
one to get the job done
recruiting an albion officer like
brielle here might be challenging
but it'll get you inside restricted
albion areas don't mind me just doing
v-con for a bunch of insurgents however
do anything suspicious and she'll
probably wind up with a bullet in the
back of her head
we're missing the human element here i
can get the defense minister on the line
right now
if you feel you must
[Music]
criminals running our streets
illegals threatening our families the
police commissioner himself
assassinated by terrorists well that
seems to be enough evidence next up
we're crushing mary kelly's organ
farming operation and putting a stop to
it
that's good
the buyers expect high quality stuff
and we need a hard knot for this
impairing our frontal lobe again are we
bags don't disturb me in my natural
habitat
say hello to mickey the man lives for
his team
i put another air on the chest
and doesn't mind getting his hands dirty
[Music]
he does have a slight
drinking problem though
and he's passed out ah we'll
we'll come back to him
you know what let's go with someone a
bit more professional
it's almost crass to call him a hit man
[Music]
some might even call him an artist
here's the bastard responsible
ah done and dusted
not bad not bad if i do say so in it
not everyone in london is a legendary
assassin or a super spy but everyone can
be a hero
[Music]
so get out there find the best
recruits and build your resistance
[Applause]
it's time to take back london
plunging the player into a living
breathing city teeming with unique
locales and characters has always been a
central pillar of the watchdog series
so what goes into building those worlds
here's amanda mutt to tell us more
[Music]
my name's amanda munt i'm a level artist
on watch dogs legion at ubisoft toronto
being a level artist i think is the
coolest job in video games because we
do get the freedom to to kind of like
pick and choose what little details we
want to depict and we get ample
opportunities to tell the stories that
we want to tell in the spaces that we're
assigned to
i have the capacity to hide things and
you know like small little easter eggs
in ac unity there was a boat somewhere
in the world that was covered in cats
and then it happened again in watch dogs
2 and there may or may not be something
in london that is a boat filled with
cats in some capacity
so
i was fortunate enough to go to e3 last
year some of the people that i was
showing our demo to were from london so
no matter where i dropped them in the
city they'd go oh my god this feels like
camden this you know this feels like
suther this feels like westminster
when people are talking about some
detail that i've put into the world and
they're excited about it like that feels
so good as somebody who you know builds
these worlds with care i love it
[Music]
and now some news for brawlhalla fans
in just a few weeks you'll be able to
battle it out with your favorite legends
on ios and android devices
[Music]
three
two
one
[Music]
and now whether you need a tom clancy
action fix on the go or want to dive
back into one of the most beloved
fantasy franchises in gaming we've got
you covered
[Music]
[Music]
the target is being held on the ground
floor
okay
contact mode chain is down request air
support target northeast rooftop
roger inbound danger close
i need an emp deployed now
[Music]
get back in yourself
[Applause]
hey take this
don't make me regret this
speaking of tom clancy it's been five
years since rainbow six siege first
launched and the community has never
been stronger in celebration of this
milestone ubisoft montreal has put
together a special video to thank all
the amazing players and developers that
have helped siege become the game it is
today
[Music]
in december 2015 a small team released
rainbow six siege
a game built on a strong vision
creativity
competitiveness
and team-play
that original vision was quickly adopted
by our passionate community propelling
it to a whole new level
[Music]
dive into our new operation steel wave
update available now and take ace and
melusi out for a spin
a few days ago we introduced y'all to a
brand new multiplayer shooter
now it's time to venture into the
hyperscape
wait
what was that
a hack and a hyperscape
that's not supposed to be there
let me get you all up to speed okay
about 30 years ago everything that we
feared about our future started to come
true we made some good decisions
we made some bad decisions
actually we made a lot of bad decisions
so here we are
10 billion souls living in the crush of
the mega cities
but the people at prisma
changed everything
they gave everyone a way out
the hyperscape
in the hyperscape the biggest draw by
far is crown rush
this is where anyone can become someone
[Music]
if you get good at crown rush
it can change your life
[Applause]
but strange things have been happening
lately
rumors of people getting hurt
users disappearing from the real world
a darker secret lies at the heart of
hyperscape
and we have to find it
some of us are searching for a way up
some of us for a way out
and for others
a new way all together
that's what brings us to the edge of the
future
to the hyperscape
i'm jc creative director on hyperscale
jc's work on far cry primal and multiple
prince of persia titles has established
him as a top creative here at ubisoft
for me what's exciting is uh we started
building it from scratch seeing it grow
adding ideas is really cool
hello contender welcome to the
hyperscape the game takes place in 2054.
it's in the future where humanity has
grown a little darker
one of the companies there they are
launching what's called the hyperscape
which is a virtual world and the
internet of the future it's the place
where everything converges
within the virtual world there is a
battle royal that takes place in the
virtual city of new arcadia
then we also introduce a lot of new
things
you get the opportunity to do parkour on
the rooftops to grow into interiors
where it's much more narrow much more
stressful you get to go to the landmarks
where there's more opportunities to get
full items but also more players so it's
a risk reward kind of deal
we introduced the notion of hacks
special abilities that you can pick up
on the fly to adapt your tactics with
hacks you can do things like teleport
yourself you can wrap yourself into a
ball and bounce around the battlefield
so a lot of abilities that let you have
fun that are toys that you can play with
finally it's made as a spectacle so all
the viewers will be able to interact
with the game on different levels
through the twitch extension
so every few minutes there's going to be
a vote and viewers will be able to
decide what effect they want to affect
the whole battle so things like changing
the gravity
infinite ammo or stuff like that so
players while this happens really have
to adapt to all kinds of stuff that is
happening
so for me it's really exciting because
right now as we speak we are launching
the open beta and so it's going to be
available for free to play for all pc
players worldwide i really want to thank
all the players all the streamers and
all the viewers who participated in tech
tests and who will participate in the
open beta here's a short glimpse of what
you can expect
[Music]
watch and learn how it's done
show time
mine
let's show them what i'm made of
go time
here we go
[Music]
the digital world of the hyperscape gave
our artists and developers incredible
freedom when it came to designing
characters production manager anna maria
musca is going to take us behind the
scenes of character design
[Music]
my name is anna maria musca i'm the
production manager for characters and
weapons on hyperscape
we have paid an exceptional amount of
detail to our characters we switch
different outfits different fashion
statements different tattoos different
materials until we see them as real
individuals as real people so the second
you pick a character you see them in
game you understand what their
motivations are and what drives them and
what challenges them
this was the first lineup of characters
this is our default base but even
starting from the hair down everything
has been meticulously thought of would
this person actually like this type of
outfit would this person
enjoy the type of tattoos that we're
putting on them will they actually like
to be in this
body each season we plan to produce new
outfits for these characters so we're
hoping some of our players are gonna
see the effort and maybe even correlate
some of the accessories to what's gonna
happen in the game
we're very excited to see it in people's
hands
as we move into the next generation of
gaming ubisoft has been working closely
with console makers to take advantage of
all the extraordinary capabilities these
new consoles will offer now we have a
special guest to tell us a little more
hey everyone phil spencer from xbox
with watchdog's legion ubisoft is
supporting smart delivery so you will
get the absolute best version of the
game
on any version of xbox you're playing on
on series x
you'll get to take advantage of the
amazing work the team has done with
directx ray tracing to create an
absolutely immersive version of london
like you've never seen before
ubisoft has a unique ability to create
immersive worlds
setting a new bar that continues to
drive our industry forward
i'm a huge fan of assassin's creed
i love the time i've spent exploring the
world in assassin's creed odyssey
and i can't wait for you to see the game
play from assassin's creed valhalla
that's coming up now
all right we know you've been waiting to
hear more about this game since it was
announced back in april
and now it's time for a deep dive into
the world of vikings
my name is
and i'm the producer of assassin's creed
valhalla
so a couple of weeks ago we announced
assassin's creed valhalla and the
reaction from the fans was just amazing
the time period of vikings is really
really inspiring
when we did our research we found that
you know there were not mindless
barbarians
vikings were actually farmers trying to
find new lands for them to settle
and so they had really human motivations
so for us to have this opportunity to
tell kind of the real story about
vikings and kind of separate ourselves
from the myths and the folklore is
really something that drove us to make
this game
the team went to norway and england to
take the same roads that the vikings did
to really experience what it meant to be
a viking at that time
[Applause]
and then leaving
norway which is barren but majestic and
just coming by boat
in england and see those rolling green
hills full of sheep full of life
is just this moment that
most likely the vikings felt as well you
need to see this land of opportunity and
this is exactly the feeling
we want players to experience in this
game
[Music]
it is a personal adventure you know it
is the story of avor a viking chieftain
avor is either a male or a female you
decide when you start the game
they will have to leave norway to settle
in england because you just can't live
in norway anymore there's too much
political pressure no resources
available
obviously in england it's full of
anglo-saxons and other people and they
don't really want you there so you will
have to fight your way there to kind of
build your own settlement and see your
clan prosper
vikings were brutal warriors
and the fact that they were mastering a
lot of weapons coming from the medieval
times really inspired us to kind of
revamp the fight system
to leverage the brutality and the
intensity of viking combat
vikings were not only fighting to face
they were masters of stealth and
deception when needed they used
basically any sort of tactics they could
use to win the battle so we want to
portray the full range of combat that
you can imagine coming from the vikings
we are very happy to finally be able to
show you the game we're all been working
on so please enjoy this deep dive into
assassin's creed valhalla
[Music]
in assassin's creed valhalla
you will relive the epic saga of the
viking invasion of england
you play as avor a viking from norway
who will lead his or her battle-hardened
warriors across the north sea to the
british isles
avor is driven by an ambitious goal
to build a thriving north settlement in
a hostile land
for the good of our plan it is time we
go our viking
today we raid the tomorrow we may build
england is a dark age tangle of broken
kingdoms and warring dynasties a land of
opportunity and riches
as you prowl england's rivers by
longship you may raid locations you spot
from the shoreline
ground your ship and blow your horn to
lead your raiding crew into battle
your crew will assist you in all your
raids
fighting enemies
battering down doors
and stealing cargo too heavy for one set
of arms
whatever riches and resources you
pillage may be used to develop your
settlement giving you access to useful
services better tools and new settlers
at the heart of your settlement is the
alliance map
it will serve as a record of the allies
you have made and a guide for future
opportunities
the viking age was a time of warriors
and legends
in valhalla you will find the largest
variety of enemies ever assembled in an
assassin's creed game
every archetype offers a unique
challenge
some will coordinate with their allies
for special attacks while others will
use nearby objects to their advantage
including the bodies of fallen warriors
to face these attacks you must find and
exploit your opponent's weaknesses to
gain the upper hand
take the fight to your foes with a host
of brutal new combat abilities snare
them with a viking harpoon
pummel them with throwing axes
incapacitate them with the new stun
system to keep them at a distance or
finish them off
duel wield any two weapons you wish to
unleash a deadly combination of attacks
your fighting style as you see fit and
become a legendary viking warrior
together
all combinations of weapons are
available to dual wield including two
shields
not all situations call for violence
in this new land a viking must find a
way to adapt
as evil is not welcome in england
you may need to outsmart your enemies
avoiding unwanted attention in towns and
bustling cities
use avor's hood and cloak to blend with
crowds and slip past watchful eyes
an unseen hunter among the people
from capital cities and villages to the
dense forests and rolling hills of
england
exploration is vital to keeping yourself
sharp
you must feed off the land if you hope
to endure
hunt and forage to replenish your health
and fortify your equipment
search pagan temples and roman ruins for
new activities and challenges to
strengthen yourself and your settlement
the more you explore
the more of england's secrets you will
reveal
but as you push deeper into england the
enemy will push back
in a series of climactic moments
assassin's creed valhalla will feature
massive assaults in which you lead
avon's army into battle against heavily
guarded saxon fortresses today we will
reclaim her
today we fight for your land and
tomorrow
we rebuild foreign
assassin's creed valhalla will transport
you to wondrous and haunted lands
inspired by norse myths
and england's pagan roots
it will challenge and surprise with
unforgettable characters
thrilling triumphs
and tragic losses
giving you the chance
to live your own
viking saga
[Music]
9th century england is truly unlike
anything the franchise has seen before
assassin's creed valhalla were released
this holiday season on xbox series x
playstation 5 xbox one ps4 pc and stadia
we're close to wrapping up today but
before we go our ceo eve guimo is here
to share a few words
i hope you will have enjoyed what you
have seen today
and that you will love playing these
games
i'm proud of our teams for delivering an
ambitious broad and creative lineup of
games
and we haven't shown you everything yet
in fact we have a lot more to come
so you will have another ubisoft forward
to reveal even more about our upcoming
games
but before ending this show
we have one more thing to share with you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
it's beautiful amigo
perfect
but useless
i have something for you diego
give me your hands
papa now
the grenade is simple
it has four basic parts
the shell which contains the explosive
diffuse
the handle
and of course
the pin
what are you doing
breathe
the pin
simply holds the handle in place
it is only when you let go
that this grenade goes boom
follow me
now
i am el presidente
which means that someday
you
will be a president
and our people
they do not know how to be happy
they are torn apart by opinions
noise
indecision
strangled by their own freedoms
and even if you have love in your heart
even if you want what's best for them if
you only want to save them from
themselves
they will hate you
everything you say
do
believe
will be wrong
[Music]
they will answer your screams
call you evil
a monster
and give you
this
so you tell me
are you
and are you
a monster
because our country
is like this grenade except it has two
basic parts
our
people
and you
and you must clutch them nice and tight
or
we all
go
boom
do you understand now
and with that we're wrapping up our
first ubisoft forward
today we've seen the next generation of
a